[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
his supporters wait to find out if he
will be kenya's next president
tuesday's election was the fifth time
odinga ran for the top job and this time
the veteran opposition leader has the
backing of outgoing leader uhuru
kenyatta
here in western kenya his supporters
seem confident what i know in
this election
if something is wrong we will go to
court
yeah i know that will go to court
because i'm very sure my president is
going to win
[Music]
wait for us
coming
the people of kenya odinga's main rival
deputy president william ruto is also
confident of winning he portrays himself
as a champion of the poor a man who rose
from humble beginnings many kenyans want
change that means transformation of
their lives
and whether router will be that kind of
a person if he actually wins the
elections uh it's time that will tell
despite some logistical and technical
challenges tuesday's polls were largely
peaceful but turnout was lower than some
previous elections
kenya has a history of election violence
with rival politicians refusing to
accept the results and accusations of
fraud although some kenyans might have
voted along tribal lines for most people
here the economy was the big issue they
want the next leader to address the high
cost of living unemployment and
corruption
the final result from the electoral
commission is expected in days the
winning candidate must get 50 plus one
vote otherwise there will be a runoff
harumatasa al jazeera kisumu kenya